do you have
any clue who's who satoshi nakamoto is
is that even a interesting question
well is it you your question by the way
are very interesting
so and i think so i would say first of
all
it's not me okay and i can prove it
because you know
if i was the dossier nakamura i would
have not found an algorithm
takes totally different principle to to
approach to the system
but the other thing who is tadashi
nakamoto you know what the right answer
is
it's not him or she or them
satoshi nakamura is bitcoin
because to me is such a coherent proof
of work but at the end the creator and
the creation identify themselves
so he says okay i understand the
michelangelo okay he did the resistant
chapel fine
i need the way some peter's dome fine he
did uh
the the most of the pieta studio fine
but besides this who was michelangelo
that's the wrong question
is his own work that is michelangelo so
i think
that when you look at the bitcoin is
a piece of work that as it defects
yes like anything human but it was
captivated
the imaginations of millions of people
has subverted the status quo and i'm
saying you know whoever
this person or people are he's living
in this piece of work yeah i mean it is
bitcoin
that's what i meant my idea the work
is is bigger we forget that sometimes
it's something about our biology once
likes to see a face
and attach a face to the idea when
really the idea is the thing we love
the ideas the thing that impact the
ideas the thing
that ultimately we you know steve jobs
or somebody like that we associate
with the mac with the iphone with just
everything he did at apple
apple actually the company is steve jobs
steve jobs the man
is uh his uh is appeals in comparison
to the creation and the sense of
aesthetics that
has brought to the daily lives and very
often uh
aesthetic wins in the long in the long
in the long end and
these are very elegant design product
and when you say oh elegance a very few
people care about it apparently
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people do because we are
attacked by beauty
and these are beautifully designed
products
and uh and uh and you know and they've
uh
in addition to ever the technological
aspect of the other thing and i think
yes that is uh yeah as dostoyevsky said
beauty will save the world so
i'm with you on that one great
you